arthur car on souffre de parrot smith
est à dire qu il perçoit mal des odeurs
connu à gauche bobo en god vraiment au
bon l'adolescent était pourtant amateur
de krusty avant de contracter la coved
19 maintenant son alimentation se résume
à des barres pas et des breuvages
protéines et c'est à peu près tout ce
qu'il arrive à avaler tellement tristes
ou déprimés
fois les fois que je suis vraiment je
suis vraiment triste parce que
mes
résultats et ne mange presque plus et il
a perdu une douzaine de kilos en trois
mois c'est rien de le voir que il cluzel
email peuple n'en mangez donc ça nous a
fait que les soupers attabi s'il on en a
presque plus inquiète sa mère
multiplient les démarches et les rendez
vous médicaux dans l'espoir de guérir
son fils mais pour l'instant personne
notre solution pour elle même l'hôpital
sainte-justine spécialisée dans les
soins pour enfants affirme ne pas avoir
eu à traiter de cas similaires
j'aimerais ça avoir
spécialistes qui nous prennent par la
main et qui nous disent voici vous allez
essayer ça j'ai quelque chose j'ai un
traitement pour vous même si c'est pas
encore reconnu
ces ions le pour avoir un espoir parce
que pour l'instant dans le pot elle
s'est aussi tournée vers le dr johannes
facinelli spécialiste de l'odorat il
souligne qu environ 60 % des adultes qui
contractent la coved 19 développent des
troubles de l'odorat et 90% d'entre eux
leur trouve relativement rapidement on a
très très très peu de connaissances sur
le trouble de l'odorat postural chez les
enfants parce que c'était extrêmement
rare avant au québec il n'existe aucune
clinique spécialisée pour soigner les
troubles de l'odorat poste coved 19 tant
pour les adultes que pour les enfants je
peux comprendre la frustration est aussi
l'angoissé de cette mer là et j'espère
qu'on va trouver des solutions des
solutions qu attend impatiemment arthur
qui a hâte de recommencer à manger les
petits plats cuisinés par sa mère ici
marie motant drian radio canada québec